Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Silvia Allone
La musica è importante.
È probabilmente più importante
di quanto voi pensiate.
La musica è uno degli strumenti
di connessione emotiva
più potenti che ha l'uomo,
perché impatta sulla vita delle persone.
Se ci pensate,
impatta in maniera significativa
sullo stato psicofisico, sull'umore,
su quello che noi pensiamo,
sulla nostra percezione del mondo.
E quindi, indirettamente, anche su quello
che noi facciamo ogni giorno.
Diciamo che è un oggetto da maneggiare
con cura, con responsabilità.
Io, personalmente,
vedo quattro dimensioni
della musica molto importanti,
che hanno un effetto rilevante
sulla vita delle persone.
La prima dimensione è quella interiore,
quella con noi stessi, il ricordo.
Pensate un attimo:
quando ascoltate un brano,
un pezzo musicale che avete ascoltato,
magari, 30 anni fa.
Ha la capacità di portarvi in quel momento
e farvi sentire esattamente
quelle sensazioni.
Forse solo l'olfatto
ha quel tipo di impatto.
Secondo punto: la terapia, la cura.
La musica è, evidentemente, importante
anche per la cura, per la terapia.
È scientificamente provato
che ha un impatto diretto
sull'ormone del piacere, la dopamina.
Esattamente come il sesso e la droga.
Vi do un consiglio:
sostituite la droga con la musica.
Sul sesso fate voi, non c'è problema.
(Risate)
Seriamente,
è in grado di lenire il dolore,
anche fisico, delle persone;
è in grado di aiutare le persone
in situazioni di stress e di depressione.
È veramente fantastica
dal punto di vista terapeutico.
Ma è anche importante
dal punto di vista dell'apprendimento,
perché la musica ci insegna ad ascoltare,
e ascoltando si impara.
È dimostrato come la musica
abbia un impatto
direttamente sul QI delle persone,
sul quoziente intellettivo,
sulla capacità di concentrazione;
e la capacità, anche,
di fare cose con produttività.
Questo effetto viene
chiamato "Effetto Mozart".
(Musica)
Una seconda dimensione della musica
è quella spirituale:
il collegamento con il sacro,
con il mistero, con il divino.
Avete ascoltato una melodia
che è tipicamente cristiana,
unita con una melodia
e con un timbro, con un'armonia
che invece fa parte del mondo arabo.
È un'unione fra due religioni
in uno stesso brano.
Ecco: tutte le religioni
più importanti al mondo,
più diffuse al mondo,
in realtà hanno dato
grande importanza alla musica.
Mi soffermo soltanto sull'Islam,
perché addirittura l'Islam divide
in due tipologie la musica:
quella lecita, "Halal",
e quella non lecita,
quella proibita, "Haram".
La prima è quella che ci mette
in una situazione di pace con noi stessi,
e ci mette in contatto con Allah.
La seconda, è tutto il resto della musica.
(Musica)
La musica ha, anche,
un'altra grande caratteristica:
quella di unire le persone,
un determinato ceto sociale,
un gruppo sociale
che ha lo stesso interesse,
gli stessi obiettivi
e anche gli stessi valori.
E questo è successo in molti casi:
nella storia, la musica
ha accompagnato le rivoluzioni.
Dalla Rivoluzione Francese,
la musica popolare contro i nobili
e le élite nobiliari di quel tempo;
100 anni più tardi,
il Risorgimento italiano.
Se vi ricordate, quando gridavano
davanti alla Scala "Viva VERDI!",
in realtà quello era un grido politico:
Viva Vittorio Emanuele Re d'Italia.
La musica come strumento di lotta
contro l'oppressore austriaco.
E fino al 2010, nella primavera araba,
dove il rap è stato importante
per accendere la rivoluzione in Tunisia.
Ma è stata importante, anche, la musica
per unire la generazione degli hippy.
La musica, in quel tempo, era fondamentale
per tracciare un solco
rispetto alla generazione precedente:
così come è stata determinante
per i diritti dei neri afro-americani,
in America e nel mondo.
Se pensiamo alla musica black,
con il soul, il blues, il jazz,
l'hip hop, il rap, il trap,
è tutta musica che è stata fondamentale
per unire i neri americani,
e le loro tradizioni e le loro culture,
verso una lotta per i loro diritti.
(Musica)
Questa è la dimensione
che mi piace di più,
è la dimensione più forte:
la musica per risolvere
i problemi del mondo,
per contribuire a cambiare
il mondo in meglio.
Questo è successo in diverse situazioni.
Ne cito due, nella musica classica,
interessanti:
alla vostra sinistra
c'è José Antonio Abreu,
un maestro d'orchestra venezuelano
che ha inventato "El sistema",
cioè un metodo di fare
integrazione sociale
attraverso l'educazione musicale.
Ha salvato dalla strada
900.000 bambini venezuelani,
e oggi questo sistema è applicato
in tutto il mondo e anche in Italia.
Alla vostra destra, invece,
ci sono due altri direttori
d'orchestra importanti:
uno israeliano, Barenboin;
e l'altro, Said, palestinese,
che nel 1999 formano
la West-Eastern Divan Orchestra,
che è un'orchestra che ha musicisti
che vengono dalla Palestina,
dal mondo arabo e da Israele.
La musica come strumento, anche politico,
per unire due Paesi
che certamente amici non sono.
Ma la cosa interessante,
al di là della musica classica,
è che la musica rock e pop -
che ovviamente, in termini di impatto,
hanno avuto una rilevanza
dal punto di vista
del miglioramento sociale
e delle problematiche del mondo,
sia ambientali che più
squisitamente sociali.
Molti sono stati gli artisti
che si sono impegnati
e sono diventati, anche,
dei veri e propri attivisti,
come Sting o come Bono.
Però c'è un anno importante,
in questo genere musicale, che è il 1985,
dove a luglio si realizza
il più grande evento mai realizzato
nella storia del pop e della musica:
un miliardo e 900 milioni
di persone collegate,
il 95 percento delle televisioni
presenti, 16 ore di diretta:
"Live Aid".
Bene, mi sono chiesto,
rispetto a quello che succedeva -
vedo che ci sono anche molti ragazzi,
e probabilmente non hanno vissuto
come ho vissuto io quel momento.
E quindi mi chiedevo:
ma in questo nuovo millennio,
la musica ha lo stesso tipo
di impatto sociale,
e la stessa responsabilità?
È così in grado di muovere le coscienze?
Be', probabilmente
si è un po' sopito questo aspetto,
almeno io la vedo così.
Si è un po' assopito, sicuramente,
nonostante di fatto
la potenzialità della musica,
con le nuove tecnologie,
è fantastica, è esplosa.
Pensate a Internet.
Pensate allo streaming.
Pensate al fatto che, oggi,
ognuno di noi può sentire
in qualsiasi momento,
e in qualsiasi luogo,
qualsiasi genere musicale
nel proprio smartphone.
Bene: tanto per dirvi,
questa artista, che non ha
neanche 30 anni, Taylor Swift,
è un'artista che ha un numero di follower
che è il doppio di quello che ha
il Presidente degli Stati Uniti.
A gennaio è uscito un brano
che nelle prime 24 ore è stato ascoltato
da 40 milioni di persone.
Quindi capite quanto è importante,
quanto può essere impattante
il ruolo di una celebrity
rispetto ai temi di cui abbiamo parlato.
E devo dire, soprattutto
rispetto ai giovani.
Vorrei consigliarvi una cosa:
se avete dei figli e dei nipoti,
chi ha dei figli dei nipoti,
e volete capire cosa loro pensano,
cosa veramente sono le loro paure
e le loro preoccupazioni,
e le loro ambizioni,
ascoltate la loro musica,
fate lo sforzo di capire cosa ascoltano,
e capirete molto di loro.
Per questo motivo,
l'anno scorso abbiamo dato vita
a un ecosistema, "Music Innovation Hub",
a Milano,
che si occupa di musica come bene comune,
musica in quanto strumento
di integrazione sociale, di educazione,
di promozione della cultura
italiana nel mondo,
e anche di innovazione tecnologica.
Be', non so se vi ho convinto:
se non vi ho convinto,
onestamente datemi l'ultimo momento
per passare a una data, una data triste.
Nei giorni successivi
all'attacco alle Torri Gemelle,
Clear Channel, il principale
network americano di radio,
emanò un editto
con 160 brani che non potevano
essere trasmessi dal loro network.
Tra questi ce n'erano molti
che erano collegati
al fuoco, alle Torri, alla caduta:
quindi non volevano urtare
la sensibilità del popolo americano.
Ma ce n'era una
che non aveva nessun significato
che fosse in quella lista.
Una canzone che parlava di pace,
forse il più bell'inno laico alla pace,
ed è stata censurata.
È stata censurata perché, probabilmente,
era poco coerente con i voleri
di un'amministrazione,
e di una parte dell'opinione pubblica,
che voleva scatenare una guerra
subito dopo quel momento.
Ebbene, io chiedo una cosa, a tutti voi:
di cantare gli ultimi 15 secondi
del ritornello di questa canzone,
che tutti voi conoscete sicuramente.
Non fatelo per me:
fatelo per tutte le volte
che questa canzone
non è mai stata trasmessa.
E soprattutto, fatelo per tutte le volte
in cui il messaggio di questa canzone
non è stato rispettato.
(Video)
(Musica)
Bravi. Grazie.
(Applausi)